lui était déjà atteint du coc vite 19 un
mois avant l'apparition des premiers cas
en france son nom amirouche a marre il
faudrait donc office du nouveau patient
de nouveaux patients 0 est la fin du
mois de décembre cet homme de 53 ans
s'était rendue aux urgences de l'hôpital
jean-verdier à bondy en seine saint
denis pour ceux qui pensaient être une
grosse grippe mais après une double
vérification du service de réanimation
dans lequel il a été admis il était déjà
porteur du coronavirus il témoigne de
son expérience au micro d'rtl france bon
après on change et là ils ont commencé à
faire des examens la président husson et
après tout je pense 3e après man
remonter un temps mort de réanimation il
faut que vous messieurs et oxygène ce
que j'avais vraiment du mal à respirer
et le sang s'arrête pas de la veille
jusqu'au matin je continue à cracher du
sommet la de lloret montrent de plus en
plus là de leur montre pas franchement
d'aix et c'est des coups de couteau sur
le terrain ça sonne je dis oui bonjour
et indivisible zoom sur la mare jeudi
si monsieur m'a dit vous étiez admis à
l'hôpital là chez nous au mois de
décembre et le 27 décembre et pour une
grippe saisonnière mais appartenait
apparemment il va baisser
si vous avez eu le coc u19 monsieur m'a
dit comment ça se fait au fil des âges
s'étaient mois de décembre dadis ici
vous avez vous été positif au corps 19
et se sont retournés hier aux examens et
aux patients qui ont passé au mois de
décembre et début janvier des patients
qui sont malades
pour des problèmes de grippe saisonnière
normale sera les 24 patients il m'a dit
vous êtes le seul à être positifs qu'on
me dise non on est passé à côté de
quelque chose mais c'est vraiment c'est
très douloureux est vraiment très
mauvaise expérience
dieu merci
franchement j'ai échappé à quelque chose
ouais c'est mortel que moi des milliers
de gens